wer weiß was witzig ist diesmal ein
pfeil schießt man fall ja immer noch
ganz weit oben irgendwo und wer flott
gucken dich feld und herzlich willkommen
zu einem neuen video heute spielen wir
jump league mit dem wie nie
und heute haben wir wieder eine
challenge es ist der eine mit crossing
shader leute schaut euch das an sagt das
erstmal da fällst das ist er ab jetzt
das ist der absolute oberkörpern
ich war ein richtiger ich hab schon die
erste kiste ich auch ich rede so
darunter fallen die ganz irgendjemand
hat in die kommentare geschrieben dass
wir mit dem engel christus shader job
ich blogge und ich bin und jetzt machen
wir's einfach gehört leute das hat er
getan
das ist so schlimm wie zu hause sagt das
ganze einfach so gebogen nach vorne
werden zuerst fällt alles nach unten du
springst runter ja und da geht also
musste ich zu dir hin soll ist als als
wärst du irgendwo schwarzes loch oder so
ich hab einfach den letzten sprung nicht
und allem deshalb weil die abschnitte
einzuschätzen bei mir ist das hätte ich
habe ja schon 1000 30a 1040 games ist
mittlerweile routine
man kennt viele module auch nicht mehr
das ist für mich glaub ich vor das
problem ist man ganz bewusst kenne ja ja
ich bin halt khan jagt leute ich bin
nach bahnverkehr nach fiktiv klettern
die aussage aber bei mir lag ein
bisschen also ich hab irgendwann
leichten delay wenn ich mich zu öffnen
will kommt aber so ein kleiner deutscher
let's play heraus ist die kiste
das ist der hammer
also für alle die sich hier die den
waikiki sie schauen konnten und dass ihm
übel wurde das hier ist next level
man sieht aber easy kisten was ist wenn
ich hatte irgendwie so gebogen sind
gezerrt
als optimist doch gott oh gott wo bist
du schon bist du bei diesem banner modul
schon beim grünen
da habe ich schon fertig bin echt happy
end nicht echt am marienplatz 2 d crnjac
auf 4 tanja spiel jetzt beim modul 5
und wenn ihr denkt das hier ist schlimm
wartet mal dass death match ab pvp ist
mit diesem shader unspielbar
das ist der absolute killer in europa
modul 55 finde ich hart schwer muss sich
zeigen
bei der weite sprünge sind und man kann
das nicht einschätzen ist eine 200 das
erste mal einfach drüber diese drei
wörter double schaffen kann ja gott oh
gott ich kann
es ist echt schwer katrin 21
samedi grad so was von krank glaube die
ganze drunter welchem spiel bringen will
aber es zu spät er bei mir auch so und
wenn ich jetzt einen tollen bin ich
immer viel zu weit
lasst mich das nochmal schaffen oder der
kiste drin nur am strand und mee och ja
wohl eher wollte er wolle gott oh gott
leute hast du die zweite mit sprints
nina doch ich bin jeden tag vorbei da es
liegen also im sprint anspringen und ans
nicken in der luft ach so machst du okay
ich bin einfach nicht gesprungen jetzt
alles geklappt springen
natürlich halte die körper mit
ballwechsel show passt denn dahinter
kommt ihr her gibt das video doch erst
am sonntag leute extra denkmal auch noch
auf damit er in guter qualität was aber
leute ich sagen werde dass heftig findet
dann wartet einfach pvp ab pvp ist der
knüller mit diesem kader es ist so
ekelhaft ja ich schaff das modul hat
einfach nicht berufen die zweite sind zu
hart für mich ja erst richtig schwer
also wo die kiste springen musste wurde
auf den länglichen steht musste ja aber
wie kommt man dahin
da der leser von internetforen und lockt
gesprungen kein plan a double schaffen
kannst du ja nicht mehr weil da sind die
zahllosen drüber ich krieg das nicht hin
um ca aber ich habe eigentlich schon
relativ moderat ist ich habe schon
eisenachs und mit noch einem spread also
bei mir geht es auch halbwegs ich fühlte
mich so langsam diese bisschen zurecht
die sache ist ich habe weniger bisschen
weniger übung also man muss natürlich
fairerweise sagen einmal kenne ich hier
deutlich mehr module als als wenig weil
ich ja blick eigentlich ziemlich viele
spieler sich aber die seit 1032 1040
games und ernsthaft so habe ich mein 100
ich schaue mal durch 230 230 das heißt
habe deutlich mehr jumping routine durch
hat dem kann ich das jetzt ein bisschen
besser einschätzen und so kennen die
entfernung auch besser weil ich das sage
ich dass eine woche zwei wochen nachdem
der spielmodus heraus kam habe ich ein
video online gestellt wo ich das mit
null gespielt hat naja aber der erste
der erste mit 0 dämpft das kann ich
jetzt gerne jemand dass die ganze
versucht das expert aber das soll zuerst
gestoppt der export ist ja auch nicht so
der jump we got ist auch überhaupt nicht
dafür bekannt dass er in joplin oder jim
run generell gerne ein bisschen reinhaut
oh mann das modul ist all das ist das
modul macht dieses modul und das ist
eigentlich ganz okay diese call &
sprüngli und verpackt
colin sprung den kammern aber so schnell
einschätzen ja man das ist halt so drei
blocks sprung nach oben
ja genau sind mal die war ich am
allerwenigsten die sprünge vier oder
drei blöcken nach oben ist und die
schwinge dich an bin ich ja ich finde
gerade aus schlimmer ist drei bürger
nach oben aber jetzt habe ich grade
bisschen probleme beim modul neuen das
einzuschätzen alter schwede modulen
neuen einfach alles klar
das ist das vorbild 06 heute alter major
struggles
man gibt es ist so eklig du fliegst
einfach und die blöcke biegen sich auf
dich zu rekord und sprung gepackt jawohl
und checkpoint oder nach insgesamt war
das ist eins der ersten module mit den
red storm mit den quartz plattformen das
ist eins der ersten runde das aus kam
damals das war sogar von anfang an dabei
glaube ich red dawn und quarz also hose
schwarzen tag über redstone am boden und
schwarze und rote roller
die sache ist wir haben diese momente
öfters dass du über die module
beschreibt mit den blöcken ja ja du
hängst hat einfach was würdet ihr denkt
nie in blöcken so ich denke also ja also
ich bräuchte ein bild von den modulen zu
sehen okay leute okay leute check point
nine
dieses modul das mit dem blue wings
stellen kennst du hast du weißt du was
du richtig verpackt also dieses platform
module
da gibt es einen sprung auf eine
glasplatte drauf und ich sehe die
einfach nicht weil die reise ist und ich
sehe mich weil es zu gewalt ist ein
spricht immer auf die plattform aber der
sprung 2005 plattform
welches ist das welche nummer 7 oder 8 7
okay das ist das da das mit rot schwarze
rolle über ja ja ist schon sagt aber ich
sagte kommt dass das modul 10 ist die
hölle wo du zählen das garnicht saison
noch gar nicht sagen ich hab das modul
ist nämlich das ist modul was ich selbst
was ich sonst auch selbst ohne schneider
nie schaffe weil ich diesen letzten
sprung nicht schaffen
vielleicht habt ihr tipps und tricks und
tipps oder einfach nur ein sprung von
ihm finde ich aber dass dieser anspruch
den ich nie hinbekommen ist ins ziel 1
auch noch 30 sekunden
ja ich dass die ursprünglich nie
hinbekommen die kiste bei diesem motor
nein nein wo ist denn die kiste hier
ich bin mit diesem schnitt um bei diesem
großen leute haben herauf wahrscheinlich
in die kommentare wo ist die kiste bei
diesem studium brauchen ich habe oben
drauf weil man kann das zurückspringen
anhalt nach oben da hab ich keine jasper
ich hab halt nichts echtes zu bekommen
ich habe eine gute waffe und alles aber
nicht abgeben
dann okay fast schon egal aber jetzt
gibt pvp ist der clown
das ist kämpfen ich erkennen dass ich
noch gesagt das nämlich jetzt zurück das
ist der knüller pvp ist absolut cool ich
das an leute ja ich habe in kiel gemacht
ich bin schon zufrieden eigentlichen
danke ich mache ganz mit christa was
macht laufen weiße kerze diese gäste das
lied egoist die ganze welt dreht sich
gekehrt wir haben was machen all deine
schnauze gibt gar keine junge die sache
ist die gegner sehen ich halt viel
früher als du siehst ja weil es kommt
einmal so weit weg vor aber die stern
aber schon froh wenn i war aber ratet
mal was ich gerade aus der kiste gezogen
habe ich glaube ich glaube ich einfach
voll in den boden rein eigentlich kommt
er nicht
okay aber ich habe aber vancouver
ich bin komplett gespannt wer weiß was
witzig ist bist du ja diesmal schießt
mal ein pfeil schießt man fall
einmal nach ganz weit oben irgendwo
investiert guck dir gefällt gravity und
dass sie sogar die leute tun musste ich
meine letzte wille mir gewährt
alter schwede pvp spiel zu spiel
gespielt er mit der linken oder zumal
unten der beschreibung beziehungsweise
zum video wo luca de noch mal eingehend
vorgestellt von den schrank holen
das war es von uns danke fürs dabeisein
wenn die wenigsten verlinkt ist